[Music]
so what about a Roseanne spin-off this
mean featuring Jackie's three-time Emmy
winning portrayer Laurie Metcalf spread
like wildfire yesterday
Jackie you watched it for her anyway
coming to ABC are you available yes I am
so could a Jackie spin-off actually
happen
Jimmy Kimmel pitched his idea last night
I have an idea that I think makes this
work for everyone
America's favorite working class family
is back with all the cast members you
love coming to ABC this fall Dan CNN's
brian Stelter says a spin-off show of
some kind is not out of the question I'm
told by an ABC source it's too soon to
talk about that but when the time is
right those conversations will be had
John Goodman and Laurie have both
remained silent since Roseanne's
cancellation to the next 13 just two
weeks ago Laurie's relationship with her
controversial co-star seemed perfect but
despite that love fest Roseanne may have
the power to block a spin-off from
happening
Farr is listed as one of the creators of
Roseanne the producers might not be able
to move forward without her unless she
blesses the project unless she gives her
okay but I think she'd be willing to let
the show go on so that she is not blamed
for the loss of all these jobs well I
think we're all rooting for a spin-off
because there's a lot of innocent people
who could be out of work
you
[Music]